when we were in your house and and dude
thanks for all the gear from your your
clothing line and the house tour and
showing me your assault rifle and
and jumping off your uh [ __ ] your
roof
ah i mean that was quite the whirlwind
tour you just gave us um
and uh when we were in the house he said
that well he bought it like like a
number of years ago at a time
exactly a year ago
for 6 20 and now the area has gone up so
it's selling for 9.50 right now
that is what's happening with real
estate i'm kicking myself that i haven't
done
this area is booming and a lot of people
kind of put shade on on the lancaster
palmdale area but but guys like okay i
can ride 10 feet and then go into
40 000 acres of legal riding trails and
suicide hills and all kinds of you know
whoop-de-doops for like dirt biking yeah
is that why you chose to live out here
well i did this show called marriage
boot camp with my mom
and i got like 200 000 paid my agents uh
you know paid my mom money and i had
like 120 left over so i was about to go
like buy a lamborghini or something
stupid i was living in like an apartment
and my mom [ __ ]
excuse my language but uh can i cuss
yeah oh sure [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] um
no so she rips up the check and she's
like no
i was like what would you just why'd you
do that i want my mercer logo right now
and she's like you're buying a house
i went and i bought a house that was
actually across the street from here and
i bought that house for 420 and then
sold it for 6.20 two years later after
being my first time so when you're a
first-time homeowner and this was the
first house i ever bought in my career
or anything
surprisingly because you know i made a
lot of money but i never made the right
decisions
and didn't have the right guidance
either and so you know we i buy i
purchased this stuff my mom's like we're
going to move out to lancaster because
when we lived in florida we used to come
out to the movie desert and it's close
to the mojave desert and all that so
come out here and
i you know she's like purchased this
home you know and i i got got it for 420
and and
had to hold on to it for two years
before you can you can capital gains
yeah exactly correct and capital gains
so you can you know take houses and flip
them immediately
so now oh so that said that i wrote a
preventative if you sell it before
they'll tax you like twenty percent on
like you actually legally can't that's
just for the first time you buy a house
no for a first-time homeowner you have
to have it for two years oh yeah
if you're going through a hard money
loan and i was going through a hard
money loan with the 12 interest rate
because my credit was messed up and
you know three years taxes weren't paid
and all this stuff so i had to get all
this stuff squared away before i could
even buy a house
three years of taxes not paid like
that's pretty close to the cusp of like
pulling a
uh
wesley snipes and then anna the
situation oh right right right yeah that
was the situation i think i had to i had
to file for bankruptcy when i was uh in
in um
[Music]
because my parents didn't pay my taxes
when i was 12 13 and 14 and before i
turned 18 i grossed about 500 million
dollars
say that again
500 million dollars by the time you're
hauled 18.
[ __ ] because i've sold 75 million
records that's grossing yeah yeah so so
like yeah it's pretty crazy how you can
earn a lot of money and it all just goes
away yeah so the taxes on that's like
what two hundred dollars i mean if
you're making how much money you're 38
taxes 38 yes i'm around yeah i always
tax park at 50 yeah that's smart just
keep it in your head like only 50
percent as well well i keep in my head
absolutely especially because we're in
california and then like
well here's well here's what i'm going
to do is now i'm going to i'm getting uh
i'm either going to sell this home and
get the price that i want or keep this
home pull the equity out and purchase a
house in colorado now i got all my taxes
squared away everything so now i can get
a 2.8 interest hra loan
and i'm i can you know have my primary
residency in a place like colorado not
vegas a lot of people go to vegas
because of the taxes that's why they go
to but i'm going to go to colorado and
get like this big 48 acre beautiful
ranch you know part yeah because what
part of it oh what part um i mean i've
been looking to like tell your ride and
areas like that sounds peaceful more
peaceful than vegas probably well yeah i
don't i'm not into strip clubs i'm not
into stuff like that yeah vegas is tough
i'm more of a southern southern boy you
know yeah i wonder if you've got t-pain
beat because that we were talking to
t-pain about how he blew through 30
million bucks and then like got to a
point where he couldn't afford a whopper
wow and you're dude i've gotten there
multiple times right
i'm talking about like hundreds of
millions of dollars
like but but but the thing was
unfortunately and you know my dad's not
here but my mom's alive man i love you
mom i know you'll watch this but like
they didn't handle things correctly your
mom was your manager my mom is not my
manager she was though she was yeah she
was so she left the job of the business
management accounting to my dad
and he messed it up and he wasn't
putting the 15 of the paul peterson
coogan law money into my account
paul peterson coogan law so paul
peterson was an act child actor that
created the the law
that put makes you have to put 15 of
your children's money
if they're actors singers whatever
well
yeah end up blowing all that money
because the parents just like they take
hold of it otherwise when i turned 18 i
would have went to low hands
and then been basically like a slave did
you see what they spent it on really so
legally of course i did my dad bought
four different race boats that were
worth millions of dollars he was a
professional race boat driver um we had
four tour buses h3 prevos um we had 15
golf carts uh we had over
45 cars 50 dogs
three yachts over 70 feet um a football
field did you talk about 15 houses my
cribs episodes 15 houses
like you're wearing you just look like
old cribs these houses yeah
yeah 15 houses
right how close together were they
well they were all of our neighbors
houses and my dad wanted to create a
compound so he just made a bunch of
noise until they kicked out
wow
back to this uh freddy krueger law like
um paul peterson okay paul peterson
krueger
coogan
um
they uh they made a law
so that like
to limit the amount of a child star's
money the parents can blow
to 85
right right right you can only blow
eighty-five percent of your kids you can
only steal eighty-five percent of your
kid's earnings it's crazy and you know
what i actually have been petitioning
and working on something called the
carter law which actually makes you have
to put 30 of the kids money into an
account and then they get it in
increments 18 and then 25 and they have
to graduate certain business type
schools in order to gain their money
whoa so they know how to manage their
finances so they're gonna pull up
yeah that's not a bad idea
especially the incremental because like
yeah yeah
an eighteen year old like you don't just
thirty
i blew through five million dollars in
like a year yeah it's crazy how quick
you can spend i think i heard about mike
tyson like one year he made 400 million
but he spent 500 million that year or
something like that i think that mike uh
it was more of a 300 million dollar
situation across the
gnarly
that's insane i mean i i i like hardcore
where does it go like
you know
tell me about this errant card a lot
because i i'm i'm very interested in
that i think uh
they think you're onto something i think
so too where like
you uh
the child star
earns earning millions of dollars
and then they have to do certain things
to unlock like a correct accounting 101
class local community college exactly
how how brilliant is that really because
i'm speaking from personal experience so
if i go if i if i look at things in
retrospect and i say okay i'm 18 years
old
i get i have six million dollars waiting
for me give me two million and then
by the time
you know
25 comes along seven years later
then
you know i have to take
you know three months of business
finance schooling in order to learn
about 401ks social security and and you
know
housing and invest proper investments so
then by that time okay you blew your
money but then 25 comes along and you're
like okay i messed up i learned now i
need to buy a house
i mean the tough part for that is that
once someone's 18 they're an adult they
can do whatever they want yeah
i'm not going to school but imagine it
being put out in three different you
know 18 25 and 30.
so
in in i mean if you're gonna do that you
might as well keep keep it
keep it staggered out i would be super
stoked but it would also be making them
money if it was putting proper accounts
because it would be gaining interest
while they're waiting for right when uh
people join the nfl and i think certain
other sports leagues they like make them
take classes do they really just because
athletes it's like an epidemic
people are going broke
i think that i think they might have to
shaq doing something like that too we
talked about that with him right there's
this crazy um
documentary called broke which is just
about athletes that made hundreds of
millions of dollars that sounds good the
statistics are insane where like
90 of nba players are completely broke
within five years of their
nba career ending wow
it sounded like some like whatever maybe
getting it wrong but well i mean i i
think i think i am on to something when
it comes to that you know and it's you
know something that that that's uh
it's for them and it's a part of my
legacy too yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]